adaman eve.com is the place to go uh to
to bring more pleasure or satisfaction
in your bedroom and they are offering
50% off just about any item plus free
shipping which includes Rush processing
just enter code Lifeline at checkout
we'll talk about this more later on in
the show so that's me no it's like you
can r a girl you can r a girl so I'm Bas
Riz I'm just basically based Riz No Cap
even with this thing I'm cap cap base r
No No No Cap when you say that cap I'm
cap
B no no it's not
Captain
run hello
hello
[Music]
helloo uh we it welcome it is 8 episode
87 of Lifeline you know what's weird is
um we're getting to be up there it's
going to be episode 100 soon yeah in 13
EP in episode 100 we get to have Jesus
Christ on the episode so is coming back
but Jesus Christ is always kind of with
us on this episode on these episodes
isn't he he's always right over my
shoulder um you are missing out on the
lifeline luxury show patreon.com
Lifeline luxury that's Matt and I no
submissions just us and I just him and I
um Lifeline luxury is a great show we
have a lot of fun doing it go sign up
for Lifeline luxury right now and also
get my special it streaming or die it's
available at Chris lea.com I will be in
Phoenix and Oxnard and Sacramento and
Brea and El Paso and Albuquerque go to
chrisa go to Chris lea.com to get
tickets and that's that and that is that
and guess what you got a good story you
want to tell some tell the world about
it submit yourself as a potential guest
to my upcoming podcast coming out very
very soon now called the private record
go to the private record.com
submit yourself there I thank you very
much uh you got a question you want to
submit yourself on this show uh do the
thing in the description below or just
go to watch lifeline.com uh you want a
one-on-one advice session with me you
get the best advice of your life totally
change your life make it good for the
rest of your life from now until you die
go to mata.com and book that now you
want some good merch you want the best
merch go to Lifeline merch.com dude you
go like this you want one on every time
you say you want a one1 you say you want
a
one1 do you want a one1 it sounds like
you're um do you want a one1 you going
to get it Puerto Rican uh so
anyway get uh thank god dude that we had
Anthony
honestly no yeah getting
here why don't you tell him okay
well we were getting here you so he
texted me on the way here and you us
yeah the the the show together yeah hey
the lot that
you we usually use is uh you can't use
it it's closed off it's private rented
private today yeah so you're going to
want to park somewhere else mhm and um
I'm just like really grateful that he
kind of was able to tell us that because
I you know you go through the
situations for those of you that don't
know Anthony is you know he's one of The
Producers over there but you know you go
through the situation in your head it's
like say I didn't Anthony didn't tell me
that right I show up
I see the Lots full that I usually park
at I'm I'm like what the [__] okay what
do I all right so all right um you know
I'm discombobulated I mean I know what I
probably would have done if I wasn't
warned ahead of time but but you go like
this oh god oh and maybe you you you got
to pull over you got to start thinking
about another lot you know where is it
where do I how do I get there yeah and
then and then you go all right well I
guess I'll start looking and then you
know that could take a you know a few
minutes and then
you you just get completely turned
around and the good thing about uh that
that happened was Anthony gave us a head
of IT told us ahead of time so when we
got there we already knew MH okay this
lot is going to be
full be prepared to look for another lot
right away you know what I like the most
about it though is that he didn't give
us options for other ones so he
basically didn't need to do that in any
way because not would we have found out
on our own but we would have had to also
on our own without his help find out
where would be a good place to park
right now if I wasn't warned ahead of
time like he did I would have gotten
there realized it was close cried parked
called my mommy right and tried to
figure out what the heck on Earth I'm
going to do now yeah do you want to know
why I told you guys yeah sure it's a
one-way street so if you turn down that
Street then you have to go like all the
way around you
know interesting and he's just being
considerate just being considerate you
yeah but it's like you needed to where
did you park though like just telling us
isn't enough you know and yeah where did
you park number one but number two I
just feel really badly that nobody gave
you a heads up when you got here when
you got there you probably go like this
oh
oh and then you were like you know what
I'm saying it pays to be first yeah so
thank you so much for telling us that
and and saving us really the high cost
of being the first one yeah
um and uh I have news for you Matt
remember when I was so late to the show
yeah like an hour more you were two
hours late dude yes you are hours late
okay well more yeah was I was an hour
and a half late you're right
um I got here in less than 40 minutes
today and you said no I I know I know
exactly what I said it was the correct
thing which is that if if we if we start
at the right time understand you will
not hit the same traffic you did say
that but you also said it always takes
at least 40 minutes to get here from
where I am and it didn't this time how
many minutes did it take probably like
38 that's 40 dude that's basically 40
it's close enough but now I woke up this
morning and okay so I woke up yet last
morning yesterday morning and I was
great to go I was good to go and I was
like let's do this took Calvin to school
and on the way to school Calvin said
Barbie Barbie uh drives a a pink car
just out of the blue we had a
conversation about that dropped them off
and went about did my day okay then uh
today I woke up didn't want to wake up I
don't like that hey body what's going on
well what is going on huh well not much
is going on just I didn't do anything
crazy slept fine why did that happen and
Jesus Christ give me the answer well
he's right over my shoulder if you want
to see but I don't understand dud dude
one day I wake up one day I wake up and
it's good and then one day I wake up and
it's bad I don't understand it either
the last today so my version is yeah the
previous two days before today
previously on waking up
I felt like such doggy crap last
yesterday and the day before previously
both days on waking up okay what is that
I know that's Dennis hazur but what's
well no ABC does it it's not Dennis
hazur it's not no previously on lost
it's just the guy for ABC okay so now
that we got that um don't stick me up
for that okay well so go ahead uh today
I was like last night in fact I was like
oh no another morning is coming soon I'm
going to feel terrible because that's I
guess what I do now in the morning and I
don't know what I'm going to do woke up
today felt great waited to feel terrible
cuz it doesn't come right away which is
the weirdest part uhuh yeah is it
depression or what is it is it is it
physical no no no the moment I wake up I
get slammed with a Mac Truck of
depression and anxiety so that's the
first thing
okay me too dude should the air be off
or what no it's fine 40 no that's good
okay 40
minutes later or so I start to like my
body gets like so hot you know what one
of you probably knows what's going on
with that why does that happen to me
sometimes sometimes I wake up feel so
much wrong information and and and and
then like 45 minutes maybe an hour later
my body's just like on fire oh my God
we're going to get so much wrong
comments I mean all right but maybe
there's going to be you know what it is
the sun the position of the sun someone
say if you're going to be really wrong
with with the thing you say don't don't
write it in the comments people don't
think they're wrong if I know but think
about it first if you actually are wrong
don't write it here's everyone
now if you're right continue to do it
and flag me say hey Matt here's what's
going on with your body fix it I'll
marry you wait what I'll marry the
person that oh you'll marry you I got
you I got it so anyway so I put my so I
woke up this morning I took a shower
last night I woke up this morning did
not take a shower and put my contacts in
my contacts are blurry they've been
blurry since jump yes dude so that's
great things are going really great
today tired and my contacts are all
[__] up in my eye e why don't you wear
glasses when that happens cuz then what
just take my contacts out just take them
out cu cuz sometimes they settle and
it's nice oh okay but I wore glasses the
other day anyway and I I'm like a one
day a week or even more glasses guy
that's interesting yeah I'm interesting
dude are we talking about so here's the
thing dude we're talking about
interesting things and some people might
be like well you're just talking about
how you woke up yesterday and you woke
up today and then your brother said you
woke up yesterday you he woke up today
dude it's interesting and we're
interesting and I won't have it any
other way dude and I don't want to talk
about so here's the thing man I've been
watching TV shows on Netflix and on Hulu
and stuff other people might think
they're boring and I don't dude
oh and and and and it's fine what is
this turning into uh you're an
advertisement for shows no okay well
what do you mean you're saying those
shows are interesting yeah yeah and
David Sullivan when he comes over and he
watches them my friend who those of you
who don't know him which you shouldn't
okay don't want you to know who he is
but he's an actor and he says I have
awful watch history on Netflix because
when we look at or Hulu or it's it's
awful stuff and it's not awful stuff
David Sullivan is first of all not
someone to be talking about someone
else's he always wants to watch really
good movies I don't like people who
always want to watch really good movies
man what what's a name a really good he
would like if I was like let's watch
Killers the flower Moon he'd be like oh
man I'm all in okay and I'm like dude
let's just watch some dumb [__]
like there's a show on Netflix now
that's uh about you know people who do
makeup for special effects and I watch
it oh my God how boring are you dude
well it's a competition
show and
yeah and it's and it's interesting to me
and uh the characters are fine but it's
me that's cool that you that you have
interests also I watch Supernatural a
little bit the show that ran for like 28
years yeah why do you watch that it's
very bad why then why do you watch it I
know it's bad because I don't know Sam
and Dean are interesting characters and
they don't Dean is the kind of guy
that's 13-year-old girl no a 13-year-old
girl in Ottawa
the that's such dude first of all how
much did that show shoot for 28 seasons
in Vancouver it did it did it was it was
in Vancouver yeah and it's very bad
anyway we could go to submissions but I
just Supernatural is a very bad show and
two people I I am close with love that
show and I tell them how bad it is and I
will still watch it but you like it no
well no uh I don't know okay it's bad oh
speaking of bad things that I've I
haven't laughed at a movie I can't
believe this is true and you're not even
going to believe me okay murder mystery
2 what's that oh the Adam Sandler one
yes I laughed for about 5 to six minutes
I missed a whole trunk of the movie cuz
I was laughing so hard one part of the
really okay I'll watch it don't ruin it
I won't okay and if you know what it is
put it in the comments but you won't
dude it was I was dying I couldn't
breathe do you think it's the part
that's the funniest part that people
would say is the funniest part or
something weird to you okay what
happened was it now you're R the one
there's one section that's actually kind
of good and funny and clever it's and
it's a joke that's made right after that
so I was primed I was ready to I was
ready good that's good that's and then
there was a really funny joke right
after that in the next scene that it
just I died now let's get into it why on
Earth were you watching murder mystery 2
there's someone very very dear to me who
uh loves Adam Sandler okay and I we
watched the first one together murder
mystery and I didn't laugh once I was
like this whole time yeah right and that
was me for the first like 12 minutes
this time was like this so my question
still still stands why did you watch the
second one then because I care about
people okay you got to love people all
right in this life you got to love
people sure and I love people and this
was a person I love okay and it made it
worthwhile and then it turned out to be
great cuz I laughed my flippity flarity
ass off so a children's book so it's so
and it's really and it's really good it
actually way better yes Terminator well
I mean Terminator one's good murder
mystery is awful murder mystery 2's
so the two sequels that are better than
the originals are Terminator 2 and
murder mystery 2 so there you go there
you have all right cool and also
Godfather right T2 is better than termin
no no no Godfather one's better all
right let's do it let's go submission hi
Matt and Chris I'm going to make this
short um cuz my phone's an [__] but
anyway am I an [__] for allowing my
dog to pretty much steal people's like
balls off their yards oh he long story
short when we go on walks if he walks by
and he sees like a basketball a tennis
ball a volleyball he will pick it up and
he will take it and he will walk and
he's so proud of it and it makes me
laugh and it makes me happy am I
influencing like bad klepto Behavior
with my dog should I not let him do this
um cuz I feel bad but it's also [__]
the cutest thing in the world you know
seeing a dog carry a basketball it's
impressive that am I an [__] for
letting him do this um I don't know if
is that short she said keep I'll keep it
short that was really short okay that
was like 20 seconds fair enough okay uh
I'm the short police that's all she uh
uh okay
um this is what I think about that I
don't think you're an assho well that's
not the right word even if you are doing
something wrong you're not an [__]
well no but you know [__] you know
she's using it Loose Loose Loosely maybe
but she's being a loose [__] she no I
think that she if you have a if you look
dude if if I don't know what
neighborhood she's in but you got
anything on your front lawn it's gone
you got to just be prepared to lose it I
agree with that right I totally agree
with that it's like what are you doing
keeping who leaving yeah come what are
you people doing well it's it's a ball
so they probably don't care so that fine
but it's not I wouldn't say it's up for
grabs for you and your dog but the
person in the house has to understand if
I leave something out on my front lawn
and somebody takes it I'm not going to
be like what the heck is going on or
call cops this is just kind of like
that's for everyone right but also I
think you could I don't see or rather I
don't see why you can't put it back yeah
yeah I well that's the thing I don't let
your dog take it and then bring your you
know let your dog in the house then go
obviously if he brings the basketball
inside the house bring it back to the
person's lawn it was on also am I wrong
here what dog can carry a basketball
some dogs can grip it and they're just
like like really yeah pring around with
the thing on look up a YouTube
go look up a
YouTube dog carrying a basketball cuz
that sounds crazy to me it has to be a a
no it's not always a big dog come on
it's not always a big dog well maybe
maybe should talk about one of those
little basketballs then there's no way a
regular basketball there's going to be
thousands of dogs with basketballs in
this m let's
look dog carrying a basketball I don't I
don't see one I see not one it's all
baskets we're g get like airbud type
[__] airbud you know yeah baskets
they're all carrying baskets he probably
he probably honestly typed in baskets
and I'm pissed in
basketball oh yeah you're right uhhuh
yeah okay well I guess you know what I
guess you are correct she's honestly
lying we found a
liar all B pisses off a basketball is
this big dude look at how big a
basketball is look he's p
there we go there we go okay okay what's
that one that black one deflated though
okay scroll up there's another one that
you didn't click on that I'm pissed
about that's a Min one a small one
you're right when you're right you're
right so maybe she means a mini one okay
fine cuz there's no way bro maybe she
doesn't literally made up something in
your head that maybe she doesn't know
what a basketball is maybe she thinks
like a beach ball is a basketball
there's one that's a real basketball
that's deflated it's deflated okay maybe
it was deflated yeah okay okay so what
I'm say also it's bothering me how much
you're hung up on well because I you
know I'm a stickler I'm a stickler for
story are and it bothers me because it
doesn't matter at all color the right
picture color the right correct picture
especially when you're going to do a
submission on Lifeline so no you're not
an [__] but like it is kind of weird
if like you're just like so
into if you're so not you know lacad
isical on not giving the ball back and
put it back put it back you're not an
[__] you're a lazy [__] if you don't
put it back I guess yeah I mean so if
you go on a far walk and you don't put
it back here's the thing if ien it's not
the same thing but if if I forget to
take a a crap bag mhm and it doesn't
matter how far the poop is I always get
home get a bag go back and to the place
that the dog took the crap put the crap
in the bag and throw it away yeah dude
why because I don't want [__] to be in
my neighborhood just like on the
sidewalk when I walk by my neighborhood
and I see [__] I don't care even a
little bit well honestly it's because of
people like you that the world's going
as [__] is the is the reality of the
situation I don't if if if my dog shits
I'd pick it up if I had a
bag yeah but if I didn't I would be like
oh I guess that's for the
Earth if it's in the middle of like a
whole bunch of stuff where nobody's ever
walking that's different I mean I'm not
going to [__] outside J crew and
being like go ahead take a [__]
diarrhea [__] I mean come on come on
Bill uh uh uh uh Sam some people
might just out in the mall just in
[__] Hollywood and Highland next to
Spider-Man dude I used to live in an
apartment building people would let
their dogs take shits in common areas
and not pick it up all right well that's
that's not okay people do that I'm just
saying I would not do that okay okay
yeah okay wow all right
next what's going on guys Jordan from
Fort Worth I got a bit of a dilemma so
I'm a healthcare worker we do 3 12 hour
shifts I come in at 7:00 a.m. it's cold
in Texas I'm wearing a little
hoodie um I put it over the back of the
chair I go do my stuff you get report
from your night Shi person you go do all
your
work um so I go do all my stuff my
jacket is on the chair all day nobody
touches it I mean there's only three or
four of us in our department you know
everybody's out doing stuff most of the
day where's this going I come back to
the department at about 6:45 and there's
a guy sitting on it and this guy is like
one of those where it's the same scrubs
every shift a little headband band thing
every shift drinks five Pepsis dude I
mean just like it's just coming out of
his pores oh and so uh he's sitting on
my jacket dude yeah and he's sitting on
the hoodie part specifically cuz it's
like lamped over the chair like he sat
down on it it kind of like slid down so
he's sitting full on it and I was I like
walked by and made a comment I was like
oh there's my jacket and he didn't move
and I said it loud enough for you could
hear me and then I kind of tucked at it
and he didn't move and I was like was he
dead all right so then I pulled it out
and he was like what is he a [__] AP
Lo behold
dude smells like absolute [__] oh God
nice so question is do I burn it do I
burn it send him a cuz he's not a wi
request no has this guy ever heard of
laundry what do I do this it's a jacket
though you know you'd have to get a dry
said it was a little hoodie I think he
said it's a jacket with a hoodie I think
that's what he's saying get a dry clean
jacket with a hood yeah I would I would
get it dry
cleaned I mean I mean how bad could it
how bad I mean I don't look I'm not
calling n some people are stinky bro so
much that it lingers for like days on a
piece of clothing sat on it I know there
is perfume like that but you know have
you ever like dude I had this vest I
used to like to wear all the time God I
saw this uh this chick out that I kind
of knew and she's like hey what's up she
gave me a hug bro that vest I for years
I had to throw it I had to throw it away
it was for years it smell like perfume
that's perfume but you know if perfume
can do that [__] if the guy smells
like Bo fat [__] drinking Pepsi all the
time you know just [__] and also not
moving here's the rule you can
be
as slovenly gross
ugly unappealing unattractive as
don't be ugly you can be no you
absolutely can be if I was you
can't terrorize I'd pass the handsome
senses of those around you meaning you
can't smell like [__] dude if you fire
someone cuz they smell bad you can get
sued he think like [__] you're fired you
get sued yeah I believe that yeah yeah
so you got to pretend you don't know
what they smell like and everyone's like
oh I don't but I was such so good at
work and you're like yeah yeah know your
work was great I don't know it just
what's you're just like
people are just like choking behind you
smell is killer dude smell will put you
me in a bad mood just like I'll be in a
great mood there'll be garbage in the
room I'm just [__] furious all ruins
your mood dude yeah that it ruins mood's
period you should get one of those
[__] what are the the medieval times
with the the nose the dick nose with the
with the it's the black plague mask yeah
but you just put a car freshener under
it just the but we talked about this
that's before you put stuff in with rose
water yeah okay I know so why you want a
car fresher that would give you such a
headache dude I know but you know what
is um that show that I watched with the
special effects makeup the face off they
did make up with the with the dick nose
and stuff what do you mean they did make
up with the dick nose one of the guys
did makeup for the uh black plague and
he it was a guy who had a big nose that
put the he put the incense in the nose
so speaking of noses do you want to see
the thing I put in my nose so that I can
breathe better does the world want to
see I I bet it I bet the people the
viewers probably do but it's pretty
stupid honestly all right well you know
what I'm the I'm always the real man oh
oh never mind this is actually cool I I
thought this was I thought it was the
Tic Tac thing no this is made for that
dude I can't look at me tell you how
much it's changed my life it makes my
makes my life so much better you have
extra one I have many many many
different SI one for me next time you
were just G to you were just going to
make fun of it and then I'm making fun
of how it looks I I want to know how it
feels well I'm super comfortable and I
can you look at me
yeah you look ridiculous don't care
don't care feel great that's fine so so
what so that is for making your your
nostrils open to breathe 100% And it uh
and why I had a headache since I took it
out when we started the show because
it's I I was not breathing enough and it
was starting to give me a headache right
here above my eye okay I just put it in
I bet you the headache's gone by the end
of the I thought you say the headache's
gone already and and you were going to
do if you did that I would have never
Tred anything you said yeah that would
have been a Lie co but you would you
know what you been you know what you
would have been a girlfriend that's what
a girlfriend would say oh wow my
headache was there I put it in instantly
it's
gone it's deeper so anyway um but it's
true you know you know it dud you know
that's something that that that that a
girlfriend says not not a woman somebody
who has a boyfriend says
that steeper no come on dude chicks get
dudes and then they end up saying [__]
like that chicks get what about when
they get married yeah same that's so not
girlfriends you're talking about every
woman any woman a single woman would
just be like out partying and getting
drunk and [__] you're painting with a
big brush dude well I paint with big
brushes so let's do another sub B Ross
who wants better sex and who wants to
start having better sex immediately I
think probably everyone I think everyone
does and the best way to get started is
to go to Adam andeve.com right now Adam
offering 50% off just about any item and
free shipping which includes Rush
processing what that's right and more
than that Adam and Eve wants to make
your life easy they offer discret
shipping as your privacy is a priority
plus plus 100% free shipping with Rush
processing on your entire order so bring
more pleasure and satisfaction to your
bedroom it's 50% off one uh item free
shipping with free Rush processing go to
Adam andeve.com and select any one item
it could be an adventurous new toy or
anything you desire just enter offer
code lifeline line at checkout that's
Lifeline l f n Adam and eve.com this is
an exclusive offer specific to this
podcast okay so be sure to use this code
Lifeline to get your discount 100% free
shipping and get it fast with Rush
processing code
Lifeline hey Chris and Matt this is
Molly from Minnesota Chris I was at your
show in Minneapolis for the tap special
I'm so grateful I was able to be there
for that experience and Matt you're
awesome wish I could be your friend so
this is Freddy and my question for you
guys is can a dog sleep in your bed my
fiance thinks absolutely not he should
be kennel at night um because Freddy
moves around a lot and takes up a lot of
space and it readjusts but I work I
travel a lot for work and so I don't get
to see Freddy all the time and I really
like my nightly snugs with my dog um so
i' would love to hear your thoughts on
should a dog sleep in your bed thanks
guys love you I mean I get I get love
you too I feel so strongly about this
but go ahead I get it I get why you
wouldn't want to because you want to uh
if you're training your dog and you want
to start with that you know so it
doesn't pee in the bed and [__] like
that well yeah that's you know I
understand I don't care about the dog
but my my dogs sleep in my bed sometimes
but I think that uh if if you know does
it wake me up some maybe every now and
then but it sucks if it keeps waking him
up maybe he's just being difficult he's
being but you feel strongly about this I
feel very strongly about this if you are
like that if if the way her fiance is
like no dogs in the bed
period there's like
you need help you need help because that
is such like like go to bed what just go
to bed there's just a thing in the bed
too what do you care what why are you
acting like you've never heard wor
before so all a sudden you just got a
labotomy uh think then just let like
it's first of all it's it's fun having a
cute ass dog yeah but he doesn't think
so so
let's that's not the case if you don't
think it's fun than God Anthony told us
about at least be in different about it
who cares dude also it makes your fiance
happy like yeah it if even if you hate
it how much could you possibly hate it
more than it
makes yeah dude like you need help
that's what saying dude and he gets so
tired he
just but he's [__] wakes up yeah just
snaps back away cuz he's too angry yeah
yeah like this guy needs help dude I
don't know dude I think I like I like
dogs a lot it's not even really about is
it a big dog was it a big dog I didn't
see it it was a pretty big dog it was
like it looked like a doodle which
looked mad cute just somebody drew it
you mean dude I think I think it's a
picture it's a drawing of a dog
everyone's crazy in there uh shout out
to honestly I you know what's I love the
name Molly dude and that's an underrated
name for a for a woman and you don't
meet too many mollies no you don't check
this out dude love the name Freddy Molly
and the dog Freddy that's cool wonder
what the fiance's name
is anyway Molly's a cool name do you
agree you don't like it I don't dislike
it I just never thought wow I love that
every time I hear Molly like oh yeah
it's for fresh I never really heard of
Molly I don't really meet mollies you
know anyway I like the name
xandro that's not a name really no no no
it's not I just made it up uhuh any name
is a name but xandro is not I mean
that's xandro is a name with an X yeah
hey
dude losing your mind losing your
mind dude the heat the heat dude here's
what's dumb this okay I agree this is so
stupid I don't like that either why
would you I didn't it was going to be
like that so why did you show it off
then like it's like that's the feature
of the shoe and it's stupid I didn't
know it was going to I didn't know that
that was going to be how when you took
it off your foot you knew yes I already
knew because I have this shoe but before
that I also didn't know this has two
things back here that's kind of stupid
are those hiking shoes what's that are
those hiking shoes what the [__] did you
just say to me are those Solomon Solomon
whatever yeah those are hiking shoes
yeah dude oh oh all right oh I'm just
saying now now what I'm just saying
you're wearing cleats bro these are
these are cleat D bro they're not
they're cool shoes dude they're not it's
not like going hiking cool they're very
not cool dude like the shiny silver
everyone to assassinate me too Anthony
likes him no he he he says I'm on a hike
just said he lik I have black ones okay
well why are you dogging them then I'm
just saying they're for saying oh it's
like the parking lot thing he's just
saying dude did you do you do you wear
them not if I'm not on a hike oh that's
his point that that that's see that's
not wears him when he's hiking dud
that's not right that's not right what's
not right it's not right to don't wear
them hiking I I I I wear them whenever I
want and they're not you know what I
don't we're actually off this topic
let's do dude I can't wait to be off but
I'm just saying like this completely
derailed I wanted to show you the Heat
and everyone's [__] sucky though dude
they're not sucky and everyone's coming
up my throat dud that that I don't have
those bro [__] showing sick D the
[__] I don't have actual cleats on bro
look how sick those are though this is
misinformation you don't have those
those are dope though you should have
those are dope for hiking you should
have those and not the ones I wore those
in doing a
podcast I'd be a [__] piece of dog
[__] those are ill but for hiking look
at the white and purple ones though just
coming in on this floor
just those are dope too how dumb are
golfers when they're when they're done
golfing and they come in for a drink and
[__] and they're just
like look at the hyper blue dude
honestly there's no worse feeling than
walking around on a regular floor with
cleats on I hate it dude it's like nails
on a chalkboard really yeah I hate
it that's why when I'm in when I have
cleats on I'm in a room I just fly
everywhere I do not walk on the ground
you're saying you hover you're you're
not touching the ground that's not
true contacts are still BL when I want
to go to the bathroom I
go that's the that's the dumbest thing
any that has ever been said on this
podcast when I go to the bathroom I go
that it's another submission when I was
young I watched David Copperfield uh fly
it going to end in tears and then
afterwards uh I tried to fly just like
David Copperfield had done and I
couldn't obviously and I cried okay oh
wow it did end in tears we've SE seen
this guy before beautiful eyes beautiful
eyes here with the green greenish eyes
uh by the way Chris our Lord has been
exiled so I'm really happy to say that
and announce it to the world uh but onto
my question what do you guys think about
gen Z slang
I unfortunately work with a lot of young
people and they say [__] like that's so
mid or oh my God I'm literally dying
right now that's fire I even catch
myself saying saying these things
sometimes just because they rub off on
me inadvertently and I just I cringe
every time so what do you guys do in
these situations does it even bother you
guys is it inevitable or am I just
becoming you know a grumpy old man yeah
um also side note house a [__] is it
when you're riding a bus and you get up
to let an old lady sit down uh but she's
like nah I'm good you can't just sit
back down again so you just kind of sit
there and uh you know stare out the
window yeah I'll tell you what's a [__]
about being on a bus when you have to
stand and the bus is like stopping
moving most [__] wow it's doesn't say
how subit it is it's how [__] it is
yeah look dude like
this okay trying to hold on uhhuh all
right okay I and NPC jerking a guy off
um all right uh what did he say uh yeah
I think
you gota there's look slang's Just Gonna
Keep slanging we hate it language
changes fine going to do yeah if you
want to do it own it 100% yeah you can't
you got to be like dude that's fire be a
40-year-old and be like that is absolute
lit that is fire YOLO you know what I'm
saying YOLO is not a one anymore but
like if you just be like Yo dude that is
so oh that's mid dude oh dude that you
know if you don't like shoes those shoes
are mid what is mid it means not like
not as not good like like not terrible
but like it's okay like
middle what is Bass the Bas means that's
true B true yeah oh okay I know doesn't
it sound like it's a negative thing yeah
I know I thought that too when I first
found out first heard about it Bas is
good it Bas is good yeah okay like if I
go if I go yo dude check me out and
someone's like based they like me based
yep based what is Riz Riz is like
Charisma so that's me no it's like you
can r a girl you can Riz a girl so I'm
Bas
RZ I'm just basically Bas RZ No Cap even
with this thing I'm cap cap Bas RZ no no
no cap when you say that cap I'm captain
based no no no it's not Captain say
you're based you're based no say I'm
based I'm based uh cap RZ no Captain
based RZ that's me that is literally who
I am I mean that would be episode The
the title episode and we're so trying to
get clicks you know Captain based rib
rig what Captain based Riz dude wow all
right come on down to Captain Bas
Captain hey we got to talk to Captain
Bas RZ well you finally said it once
right he's a dude hey dude he's like one
of those Tik Tok guys with with the
[__] you know the stupid haircut that
they have all the Tik Tok people hey
what's up man I'm the captain how about
the young guys with hair that's like
this it's ter well that's what I'm
talking it's like their head is a skate
park that's what I'm talking about
that's the worst hair dude but that's
what I'm talking about and now you're
acting like you because you're saying
how about like we weren't already talked
about this isn't right it's like this
you just put two hands up but it's not
in the front it's the sides like a bell
their head is a skate park yeah it's
it's congrats guys your head skate park
we're all talking about the same thing
and it's absolutely it bothers you Terri
so much me when somebody says something
similar to what you said yeah no but
they're not nobody's negating what you
said they're like agreeing with you
that's not it though it's when you try
to say it like it's something that we
haven't been talking about but that that
is your own you're making up that part
because how could like you just said it
well how could you assume that I'm like
he didn't say that now I'm making it up
and saying it like that's not a thing
anyone
does
cap Riz dude you know what cap is right
no it's a lie cap is a lie cap you're
lying
and if I say dude I had the best burger
last night no cap that means I'm telling
the truth about the burger right no lie
okay okay I'm captain based RZ nice to
meet you no not Captain based RZ I'm
captain based Riz dude that's all there
is Captain RZ on base yeah all right all
right next
one what's up Matt Chris second time
call I appreciate you taking my call the
first time got a quick one for you uh
being a groomsman in a wedding I think
sucks to do oh yeah it's so much with
the tuck and the bachelor party just
it's a lot I hate doing it so much I've
done it like three times
and the balls to say uh no thank you so
awesome though that's the thing but in
my bad purse for that are you allowed to
say no if you can got any tips on how to
do it here's the deal you can't really
no no no no no no you cannot say no to
that you can't but here's here's the
deal though if you're a good guy what
you do
is
um not you get your you you I I get
married I don't Gro men it sucks I pick
all my enemies to be my groomman so they
have to do it and they don't want to
yeah when I got married I asked he was
still alive I asked Osama Bin Laden to
be one of my Grooms men MH and he it
sucked for him and it was great cuz I
pun him my Grooms men were you know and
we had Osama on double duty cuz I had
Osama been on my on my wedding both
weddings both in the
pictures Hitler uh uh Bill Gates because
he was trying to make a One World Bank
and
so just the a worldclass idiot what you
just said and I don't even like people
with trackers One World Bank he's trying
to make a One World Bank people with
trackers Joe Biden because he's a lizard
okay Joe Biden because he's a lizard and
holog Alex Jones and and a bunch of
frogs cuz they turned to water gay so
wow I don't even know that one that's
the one frogs turned water gay something
that's what Alex Jones said other way
around frogs turn water straight frogs
gay oh water turned frogs G yeah oh wow
that's so confusing sorry my bad uh yeah
seriously frogs turn the water gay Wow
have you heard about this uh my my
wedding every all the Grooms were all
the grooms in were in Isis but no go
ahead no I'm
kidding just a whole Brigade of Isis I
would like to give a speech there's
somebody behind him like
there here uh madd's getting married I
never knew him but
just terrible just beheading someone so
terrible okay go what say my mom's just
like this oh it's nice though you should
asked Nick Marquan but it was a
nice
what an idiot dude well you you said
something no one even said anything and
you said what you were going to say
something you got mad when I said the
Isis thing cuz you were going to say
something no no I was joking that was a
joke jok's on you all right well no
you're not a bad person dude you're just
a popular guy you're solute you should
be meanor to people so they don't ask
you to be in their weddings when someone
you when you know someone just okay when
someone propose a friend of yours
proposes to their soon to be wife oh wow
that's funny you start being an
outrageous [__] to them and then once
they've picked their wedding party
you're super nice again then you don't
have to be in the wedding party it's so
funny to be this guy this is like the
third time to to do it again like to
think it's going to happen again andbody
like dude I asked her to marry me for
him to look at the text and be like
this right cuz he's tired of being an
[__] yeah cuz he's such a good guy
deep down yeah also maybe look less like
you listen to the big bad budha daddy
stuff and that's just a note for your
personal life is it big bad voodo daddy
that's the name of the big bad voodo
daddies that's it is that right no big
bad big bad voodo daddies is a band is
that right Chris B it's yeah I already
know it's right I I don't ask me if it's
right is it right Chris uh it's yeah
that's right who's the one that goes
suit Ryan come on is that them I like
that [__] dude yeah I like that [__]
it's nice Big Bad Voodoo Daddy that's
what I said not daddies yeah see I knew
something was fishy no no no no it's the
Big Bad Voodoo
daddies no no see I knew something was
fishy about what you said oh that sucks
bro it was so close for like 20 years I
didn't know you did what Mom did does I
did you added an S I did I didn't know
it was a [__] 20 20 years should be
dad the Big Bad Voodoo daddies it should
be the big voo daddies it should be yeah
look at those look at all of them look
at all those daddies do they sing zuu
Riot there's too many people in that b
no that would be the Cherry Popp and
daddy Cherry Po and daddy that's what I
was doing the Cherry Popp and daddies
are Ryan come on bottle of
beer ran come on which one they do the
you and me and the bottle Mak 3 tonight
Big B Voodoo Daddy that's them yeah okay
they're cool too you and me and the
bottle Mak 3 tonight
yeah what imagine counting yourself with
a
bottle you and me make bottle make three
tonight it's a thing yeah okay hey the
three of us just a song yeah no I'm not
I'm into literal songs though okay you
and me that's two and then a bottle
tonight that's what it should
be you know a bottle and then you and me
but they a bottle is a thing and you and
me are in the same group it's a Duo so
literal put this like this
F flipping the woman over over flipping
the woman over the arm dude swing
dancing like this here's the thing about
swing dancing yeah it's very cool that
people can do that and it looks cool but
why would you do it always what I say
always what I say about almost all
dancing but why would you do it what I
say about almost all dancing Tango doing
the Tango is very cool it's hard to do
it's physically impressive it looks
beautiful why would you do it what I say
always about most dancing break dancing
break dancing the number one crumping
crumping is very cool to look at very
difficult do like that why are you doing
it well that's why I always say about
dancing why are you doing it that's what
I say about dancing but stop saying that
after every single thing that I say
because when when you dance okay so
dancing though if you dance and the
thing is music is going and you go all
right cool yeah that's cool why would
you do it not why would you do it right
no why would you move to music it makes
nothing can make more sense doing a
stylized dance you're saying why would
you do it a specific dance with specific
step what a [__] musical it just it's
confusing yeah what the [__] is this
Westside Story sit the [__] down oh so
angry about it you know you know hey
what are you a jet well that's cool
learning it for in a number of a bunch
of people doing it for show that's my
point is that that's when it's
cool at the
dentist dude when you're a jet you're a
jet all along and a jet is a jet when
he forgot the words well yeah okay so
what else what else we got we got
another one who else who else we got
what's up guys uh appreciate what you do
appreciate the podcast um you're really
really out there doing the Lord's work
hell yeah well you are um I think that's
more you so I've been listening to you
guys for a while um Matt I just watched
American animal and it was
wonderful side note I feel like I I
don't know maybe you had talked about on
the podcast before uh but you did the
thing from um that thing you do that I
quit I mean I can't do it I'm try to do
it I definitely noticed that anyway I've
been listening to you guys for a while
and I don't know I feel like that
subconsciously I've kind of picked up on
some of your mannerisms and maybe some
of the comedic timing um is this me
developing a sense of humor or am I just
being a pro hack all right thanks
guys well that was funny so is this me
developing sense humor or what or was
there a or yeah he said or did he but
you ruined it by he said or
what uh here's what's up
dude all of my life I'm sure all of your
life too me yeah well you don't didn't
know me the first three years but yeah
well all of your adult life cuz you
weren't saying words yet in the first
three years but people have that I've
like dated become close friends with
spent significant amounts of time with
together over whatever work whatever
they've ended up
talking more like me than they we're TR
lasers next what we're trbl lasers next
question no I just think people this is
just true hi I'm Clyde Drexler next
question this is just true about
everybody I think like if someone speaks
very particularly in a specific way than
other people around them who might not
speak in a more in such a specific way
will start to speak in that specific way
as well it's true of accents I don't
know if you notice people like when
around
English start to sound a little bit more
English same thing with Southern Accents
it's true of
accents um uh pace of of of speech
Cadence like draws all this [__] so it's
not like Anthony Anthony Simmons nice to
meet you you're not like ripping no like
stealing from other people or even like
aping them it just is like a natural
thing hey Chris Murray over here but
yeah why you keep saying names dude who
the [__] is Chris Murray they're they
play for the Trailblazers is that what
you were just [__] Googling you ass
no one knows who Chris Murray is dude
Ryan rert Ryan rert I I don't I only
know Clyde Drexler Clyde drexler's the
man dude okay but that was from a long
time ago but that's when I used to pay
attention to basketball and so I Googled
and [__] there's a bunch of different
guys wait are they the triers aren't
even a team anymore no I know so that's
what I really don't get here because it
says scoot Henderson and DeAndre Aon and
Shaden sharp and Malcolm Brook I mean
these are like Japanese guys that's
exactly what I thought of dude the the
Japanese baseball game so funny man um
yeah they're not a team anymore are they
no they well they moved and I think they
have a new new team so maybe that's what
it is then okay so may that's what they
were saying but a new team name and
everything but yeah no that's I don't
think it's exactly you getting a sense
of humor either you're obviously funny
already you're just like unless he
didn't had gravitated towards this
because it made you laugh and that you
have your influences it's like yeah it
fostered your sense of humor let's put
it that way yeah yeah and it's f it made
your sense of humor Bloom now listen
you're too old to figure this out flower
it's all good you're already doctor
you're too old but look you know I
wonder what kind of doctor he is I
wanted to know and he didn't say um well
maybe he's doctor of the Soul which
would be good because now he knows how
to make people laugh
um the Portland Trailblazers are still
team they they're still in Portland and
the trail lasers and they compete that's
awesome I didn't I thought they moved
there're the Portland Trailblazer still
yeah dude why did we both think they
weren't a team anymore I fully thought
they had so did I
yeah that's like the I know the
superponics moved maybe that's why I'm
mix I'm like glomming them together no
but why Trailblazers though because of
the Pacific
Northwest Portland and Seattle are
similar that's why I mean I don't know
could be it could be it so how could you
change and move the Seattle SuperSonics
that the coolest team name ever because
it sounds incredibly
gay oh Super Sonics but that makes it
cool [__] it I agree but I feel like the
ba was like this is kind of outdated
because it sounds gay iic why but yeah I
think
commission David Sterns is like this is
too gay we got to get pretty gay Donald
Sterling just like yeah we don't like
that because I'm racist you know yeah
okay anyway s SC all right do another
one yeah
sure hey Matt hey Chris so got a quick
one most beautiful how would you cope
with being made to spend a lot of time
with somebody
um who is constantly cracking jokes but
you just don't find them one bit
funny this person I'm talking about is
constantly like quoting Step Brothers or
quoting Bor which are funny movies but I
just think quoting them has been done to
death at this point um or they'll like
repeat something that I say with a
slightly different accent and then laugh
that's what makes it difficult they're
always laughing at their own jokes right
after they say it oh and I only have the
energy to give so many fake laughs back
to them before I'm just leaving them to
laugh at their own jokes everybody that
does that not laugh back at them which
just makes me look like the miserable
one so yeah any advice would be
appreciated um and I don't have a Jordan
with the slam but I think I do a good
Jordan with the slam
so Jordan with the
slim wow that was pretty good he changed
he didn't have the English accent
anymore yeah yeah it was pretty good so
wait hold on um I have a buddy that that
does that and I say for me it helps for
me in my soul it helps when I say hey
why do you do that I I asked and then
what does he say I don't know I guess I
just do that because I don't know I get
insecure and and oh wow really yeah oh
that's and I said yeah but you don't
have to do that why don't you stop and
he's like I don't I can't help it I
don't think I can help it
I swear to God this was a conversation I
had with him wow he got real real fast
uhuh yeah I would imagine glad we did it
I would imagine the answer would be
because I think it's funny he just says
cuz he's insecure yeah no no he well I'm
talking about specifically the laugh
after the thing that yeah I know but I
would imagine they laugh afterwards
because they think it's funny no no no
no because they'll be like oh yeah nice
hat oh you know it's it's like it's not
like that it's like and I say like bro
why do you do that and he's like do what
this guy and know I get what you're
saying but it made this guy made it
sound like the guy he's talking about
actually thinks he's hilarious that's
that's a little different than what I'm
saying yes yeah yes like if you're doing
a step brothers quote like this guy
doesn't do Step Brothers quot talking
about that's it's just dude what is it's
frankly the guy you're talking about I
would like a 100 gazillion times more
you do like him oh okay yeah but I'm
saying in a vacuum that's so much more
right yes likable than someone who
thinks they're [__] the most
hilarious person will stop saying of
course while I'm talking so but yeah I I
absolutely hate uh that [__] and I I I
don't know I can either not be around
that kind of person or I want to be
around that person as a study MH but but
I can't do the middle I can't be like
okay that's a friend now I have to be
like hey bud you know in my head I'm
around you because you're so interesting
and what the [__] is going on through
your head or I can't ever be around youh
you make the I that [__] [__] is so
hey dude don't do that kind of joke what
joke
a step further well yeah but the worst
part is laughing at it
afterwards man here's what here's what
you do just you're already doing it stop
giving him the satisfaction of a fake
laugh don't fake laughs too much and
then and then when you don't laugh and
he's so he does the step brother saying
he laughs he thinks it's hilarious he's
he like you know looks down because he's
like laughing so hard when by the time
he looks up this is what I want him to
see you doing this
it's yeah that's only going to help
that's not going to help the guy though
the guy will still do it you don't think
he'll be like what's happening and then
you can say look I want you to see the
face I'm making I'm not even smiling I
understand but I think I think that what
that does I think it will only make that
guy feel bad I don't think it'll help
the situation at all and it will make
the guy feel bad so how do you avoid
making them feel bad for me you say why
do you do that what's what is this do
you think it's funny or what's going on
cuz you always do it you qu Step
Brothers that's just a movie that you
saw to me that would feel better yeah I
couldn't agree more that's the right
thing oh
okay that's the right thing also you
don't feel bad cuz you're like if you
come at it where it's like yo what is it
that makes you do curious yeah I want to
know yeah I find it interesting cuz it
is
interesting then it you know also then
you might get them to actually then you
yeah right you might you might and you
probably won't I mean you might still
hurt his feelings cuz people are
sensitive about being asked about things
they do cuz they implicitly think oh
they're saying it's stupid or whatever
you know but there's nothing you can do
about that you got to be able to ask
friends why they do what they
do yeah my uh my contacts are still
blurry and it's really frankly [__]
pissing me off and I still got my
headache I took my nose thing out didn't
really make a difference it helped me
breathe it made me feel better but it
wasn't helping my headache I'm so pissed
off about this contact thing man it's
okay but I think I need to you know what
I think I need to do put cold water on
my face okay well what do you think
about that I think that people only do
that in movies and that's not a real
thing I thought about that too every
time I see someone do that in the movies
I think that is a madeup thing that is
only a meme now because movies invented
it people don't it's like people when
they're like you can't you know you
can't testify against your spouse if
you're married to them it's like movie
made that up dude yes you can be made to
testify against your spout yes but
people think it cuz it's just like what
movies is it you know I I think people
do wash their face with not wash but
like with a cold water but not for the
reason in movies that make movies will
do it because they're like I need a
reset dude yeah exactly that's never
happened okay so then why would you do
it because I feel really [__] tired
and I want cold water in my eyes to move
my contacts
around so it's not a reset though
cold water helps your eyes maybe it'll a
reset actually see you're just you're
sucker dude it's not cuz I'm stressed
out though that that's what happens in
movies they go
like okay oh I'm back to square one
that's not what I'm doing dude it feels
good to put water on your face like a
cold plunge you're saying yeah yeah no
to spash your face with water feels good
talking about well wait what do you mean
what do you mean yeah you're talking
about splashing water on your face you
think it feels good wake yourself up no
or or whatever reason ever reason you're
saying it just feels good period or
you're saying it feels good when you
wake up uh either both okay yeah when
you have a headache when you feel like
you want to wake up yeah interesting
sucker right yeah I think we just do
that saw people do simply feels good
robot during sex sex bot it simply feels
good getting it in his butt it simply
feels good are you gay no wow it's uh
just never for mind dude how about how
[__] fantastic this podcast is and
how about how share it with your friends
dude
patreon.com Lifeline luxury to get on
our Lifeline luxury patreon [__] uh grow
or die is available my special and go
see me in Phoenix I will be in Oxnard
and Brea and Albuquerque and El Paso and
a bunch of different places go to
chris.com to get tickets thank you very
much I got my new solo podcast coming
out soon private record go follow us on
Instagram and on Tik Tok and go go
subscribe on YouTube to make sure you
get the notifications when we start
dropping episodes which will be very
soon Who Am my Moses Brown what i d who
am I dup wath dude the names of these
what are you saying what are you saying
the names of these Trailblazers are
crazy oh you're still on the
Trailblazers you uh you want to be on
this show you got a question you need
some advice click on the link in the
description below or go to watch
lifeline.com you want one inone advice
with me matalia go to mata.com and of
course if you want the merch go to
Lifeline
merch.com nice wow yeah it's nice it's
nice and give the gift of Lifeline
luxury to people you love and care about
because it is great
patreon.com
Lifeline
hello
hello hello will
hello hello